hi everyone it's jerry this is game 10
from the 2021 fide world chess
championship match between magnus
carlson playing on the white end
and yan yapomnishi
going into game 10 carlson leads six to
three in this race to seven and a half
let's have a look
opening wise another petrov's defense
we saw this in game four and eight
we follow game four
for just a bit
knight takes e
d6
far far and away most popular
on this move four is knight f3
that was the move played in game four
in this game 10 it's knight d3
a little awkward to obstruct the center
pawn but know that this post by the
night is only very temporary
knight e4
queen e2 queen e7
this position if you have been following
the world chess championships
you may recall this one
when carlson played carwana this was
their game six
and in that game six
we had an interesting beginning from
this point
on move six onward
we had a string of ten consecutive night
moves
knight f4 this is the move played in
this game
and this is how the carlson caruana game
followed
knight c6
each side ended up hunting one another's
queens
each side then threatened
to land a fork
on the queen side
and these two points were defended
i'm drawing some attention to this
because maybe it had an influence on
nier pomnishi's decision
on this move six
maybe he didn't want to go down that
path
his decision here is knight f6
withdrawing the knight
queens are now in tension
main point i believe
you cut out knight d5
play continues with d4
knight c6
and a bit of a think by carlson
how ambitious do
does one want to play
this position so
d4
has some pressure on it
do you play c3 or bishop to e3
i believe the more ambitious is bishop
to e3 you defend and
well
the queens are still on board
it's c3 in this game so
still welcome to a queen exchange
neither side by the way is
so quick to bite initiate the exchange
because the other would ever so slightly
be helped
being able to recapture and develop
from here d5
ram structure on the d file
these squares
are great ones for knights or maybe even
kings in an ending
from here knight d2
knight d8 the knight on c6
optically it looks like it's developed
piece but
it's not really a great contributor it's
boxed out
really well because of this structure so
in a way knight to d8 is like a
developing move it has an idea of going
to e6 to challenge white's best piece
okay knight f3
queen exchange
bishop d6
both sides castle
rooks are in tension
and
this is not a big deal to have to
recapture and
go back maybe you even want to get to
the to the d3 square at some point
it's very symmetrical
uh the pawns not much happening on the
queen side
but what we will observe in this one is
some action on the king side with the
pawn play and
we'll get to see some
different possibilities for how
how the pawns could be moving on this on
this wing on the king's side
first it's 96
one pair of knights are exchanged
and now g3
the idea being to
fianchetto the knight we saw this in
game four
uh white
i believe had the knight on h4 and then
played g4
to vacate the g2 square
now it's on e1
going to g2
what's the idea
this is the bad guy this is the good guy
white's looking forward to a bad for
good bishop exchange
okay
first though it's f3 he does not rush
with bishop to f4
this is a good controlling move
and it's paving the way for the king to
contribute now that we're
officially in an end game
king needs to assist
so knight h5
not so fast
doesn't allow white to jump in there
king f2
solid move
on the queen side the structure on the
queen side goes unchanged for the
remainder of the game the action here is
in
uh yeah the center mostly the king side
from here now we have g4 so this is
where it sharpens up
white is driving the knight back
g7 it is
bishop f4 now
bishop takes knight takes
and the next move here is g5 i think
this is a
this is an important move
uh
if g5 isn't in white can maybe start
thinking about playing h4 and maybe
you're not able to drive this knight
away so easily
this is a best piece
right now in the position so g5 is
considered a best reply it immediately
puts a question to this post
and
decision time for white
what are you going to do
are you going to capture the bishop are
you going to fall back
the move played in the game is knight to
e2 so
still two minor pieces aboard
for each
what would happen if knight takes bishop
there's not a lot of action happening in
this one the knight would have a really
good square on f4
and
if
let's say this is a follow-up i want to
highlight this
this square is pointing out the square
d6 or d3 being good for a knight or a
king
um
check out this variation
this knight
how amazing is a knight if let's say the
bishop goes here trying to hunt the
pawns notice what this knight is doing
hitting the bishop defending the pawn
this one caught me off guard when i was
preparing for the video
i just was going to show this position
and be like
black is doing all right black's
defending
black's actually winning this position
that's how strong this knight is in this
particular case the bishop's trapped
where does it go
here
here and it eventually would have to go
there but black would go on to win the
king and pawn ending
anyhow my point here is this is an
excellent square for a knight if white
is going for this exchange there's
really not going to be any play left
okay
so
the knight sticks around
black continues now with f5
so
what's the reaction here
if
white
goes ahead and captures on f5
this is helping black
can take here
and after the recapture
what's better about white's position
i guess white can say mike king is ever
so slightly
on a better square than yours
but everything else is tipping in
black's favor open file better night
better structure right these guys are
split
so
it's important to not take here
not saying that that would be a winning
position for black but
yeah how how can black be better how can
black be worse there
what's white's plan
stay strong on this square keep this
pawn around at least for the moment
in controlling this fiend keto knight
from here we have king f7
and now rook to h1
uh some move that crossed my mind right
here instead of this king f7 during the
live stream i thought to myself suppose
black
still tries to press
and by that i mean
play h5
put more pressure on g4 and try and make
it
so that white has to give this pawn up
one way or the other
h5 would not be good
because white can take on h5 take away
from the center
and then
play rook g1
white's winning
the pawn and the game it's that serious
an advantage
so not so fast
king f7 maybe one move later this could
be played
rook h1
this rook
is on an open file this one is not
but
this is the more threatening rook
there are no entry points for this guy
but if this h file opens up
that can very easily become
a problem for black
let me
let me say that in this position instead
of let's say king f7
if black plays
f4
with
the line of thought
running
well i have some space
i have a square for a rook
i'm boxing your king out some
white says well thank you very much
i have an h file to work with
and how are you going to keep my rook
under control
the rook
and the bishop would start to interact
uh
somewhat on the king's side
the white rook is not an easy one to
tame
it is not a good idea for black to go
forward with the space invader pawn
f4
proceed with caution first king
improvement
after rook to h1 we now have black
playing solid here securing g5
anticipating some pressure one way or
the other
with f4 or h4 this is now secure
black can play h5 this is a move
i thought was an option now that the
king is
more
a little bit better positioned right
earlier i pointed out this capture and
then
bringing the rook from a1 to g1
well now this could be secured
with king f6
the
continuation here after the rook goes to
h1
is h6 but if h5 is in and we have this
capture
recapture and h4
you have to justify the rook on h1 move
or the rook h1 move you have to try and
open up the h file black will be able to
have a
an even position after this it reads
uh zeros for
almost every line i was looking at it
was just popping up zeros
this is a past pawn but this pawn kills
the king this rook plays here and
keeping pressure on it means the rook
really can't go
anywhere but
the h file and this punk could only go
so far
and if it does go too far it maybe could
even be hunted by the bishop or the king
so anyhow this is a
a way forward for black but you need to
see
blackwood need to assess that yeah this
is a
this is a drawn position not much
progress to be made
no h5 in this game instead h6
now met with f4
and black calculates
uh
the following sequence perfectly
capturing on g4
allows the h file to be peeled open
takes
bishop takes on g rook takes h
there are some threats now pawn takes
pawn
bishop g6 with the skewer
there's no time for this because you go
here get the rook and only one move
later take the bishop
so what's the plan
bishop f5 cuts out bishop g6
this allows white to pick up the g pawn
first landing a check
if the king moves we get this
guy the knight goes back
seems to be a favorite square for the
knights in this game
fianchettoed knight
there will be no rook takes b7
so white wins a pawn but it's only
temporary after king g6
and get the pawn back
and there isn't much to play for here
we have a couple checks thrown in the
king is approaching the queen side
great square for the king
if white is better it's only because of
this
well
black's knight is the only struggling
piece in the position once it's on a
good square there's nothing to play for
here
just have to watch out for any tricky
forks
rookie 6
knight on e8 only a blink away from
getting to d6
and it's also supporting something else
the rook went to the seventh
what is that something else
a rook exchange
rooks are off
move 41 king e3
a draw is agreed
game goes no further
the match
is now at six and a half
three and a half
which means
we're only one game away potentially
from the match being over one win
and it's over
so at any point
this one will be in the books
we'll see how it all plays out
let's have a look at
the tail of the tape
here we go
super high quality game
these guys are on a roll
the end of the day no inaccuracies
mistakes are blunders for either side a
three and a two for the average senti
pawn loss
okay as usual
feel free to leave any feedback to this
video in the comments section below
i hope you enjoyed it
and maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now
take care bye
you